I'm Pete hegseth in for Laura Ingram on
this Thursday Edition a special edition
of the Ingram angle thanks for being
here and we start tonight with another
layer of intrigue involving Hunter and
the Biden family's Shady business
associations watch for four years I was
senior advisor to the China Energy
company CFC
at the same time of its dealings with
the Biden family
under normal circumstances I would be
testifying before Congress about my
experience with CFC
sadly due to circumstances I shall
describe here in this video
I am forced to tell you this story via
video
there are no normal circumstances in
this case that was the missing witness
from the Biden corruption investigation
his name is Israeli Professor Dr Gaul
Luft he laid out his bribery allegations
against the president's family in an
extraordinary video filmed in an
undisclosed location while he is at this
moment on the Run
in the 14-minute recording obtained
exclusively by the New York Post The
Fugitive former Israeli army officer
claims he was arrested in Cyprus to stop
him from testifying to the house
oversight committee that the Biden
family received payments from
individuals with alleged ties to Chinese
military intelligence
the self-proclaimed fall guy says he
provided the incriminating evidence to
six officials from the FBI and the
Department of Justice in a secret
meeting in Brussels in March of 2019.
but alleges that it was covered up
over an intensive two year two day
meeting
I shared my information about the Biden
family's Financial transactions with CFC
including specific dollar figures but
perhaps the most alarming information I
revealed was of a mall within the doj
who shared classified information with
Hunter Biden and his Chinese Partners
after Brussels I never heard back from
the doj but instead of showing
appreciation for my whistleblowing I
became Public Enemy Number One
yeah they didn't have time to get back
to him he goes on to describe how over
the next four years he his family
friends and Associates were harassed and
intimidated finally in February of this
year he was arrested in Cyprus on an
extradition request from the southern
district of New York for allegedly
violating the export Arms Control Act
after his arrest he tweeted I've been
arrested in Cyprus on a politically
motivated extradition request by the U.S
the U.S is claiming I'm an arms dealer
it would be funny if it weren't tragic
I've never been an arms dealer doj is
trying to bury me to protect Joe Jim and
Hunter Biden
and he defended himself again in his
video statement I who volunteered to
inform the US government about potential
security breach and about compromising
information about a man vying to be the
next president
I'm now being hunted by the very same
people whom I informed
and may have to live on the Run for the
rest of my life
he says he's being hunted I mean those
are strong words
the New York Post reports that house
oversight chairman James Comer who was
preparing to interview Luft before he
disappeared
says he remains a potential witness in
the Biden family probe despite the fact
that he is a fugitive at this moment
love to explosive allegations well they
need to be addressed and his motive
couldn't be clearer
this does not have anything to do with
partisan politics I'm not a republican
I'm not a Democrat I have no political
motive or agenda
I did it out of deep concern
that if the bidens were to come to power
the country would be facing the same
traumatic Russia collusion scandal only
this time with China
sadly because of the doj's cover-up
this is exactly what happened
we've reached out to the doj by the way
for a comment and we have yet to hear
back
joining me now is Miranda Devine a
perfect guest for this tonight Fox News
contributor in the New York Post
columnist who broke this story also with
me is Mike Davis he's the founder and
president of the article 3 project
Miranda I mean fantastic scoop by you it
if what left says is true how does this
change the course of the investigations
not just into Hunter but into Joe
well look I think he's going to be a
witness still that's what James coma
wants to do he was already in talks to
be a witness when he was arrested
um you know he is a fugitive obviously
that discredits him somewhat but perhaps
that is the aim to stop him as he says
to stop him from testifying
um the things that he told me about the
Brussels meeting and and other facts
about the bidens have been corroborated
since he told me about them in other
ways he's given me a document to show
that that Russell's meeting was in fact
scheduled by the southern district of
New York and you know he's described by
people who knew him in Washington DC as
a credible person with deep intelligence
ties he founded and ran a sort of an
energy Think Tank which had as its
advisors such luminaries of sort of wash
Washington DC life as the former CIA
director James Woolsey former NSA
director Robert McFarlane and so he was
well plugged into Washington and he was
it is correct I have verified that he
was partners with the the very Chinese
from cefc that Hunter Biden and his
Uncle Jim Biden were receiving money
from millions of dollars and and so I I
guess he had the access to be able to
know that information
we've heard about an FBI mole before and
he's now put flesh on the bones of that
it definitely is a serious set of
allegations they should have been
investigated and it appears yet again
that they weren't he would be the fifth
whistleblower whose allegations about
the bidens were not were just buried by
the doj
yeah folks are blowing the whistle all
over the place and no one's hearing it
the game just continues Mike anyone
involved in Hunters corrupt business
dealing they're not going to be a Boy
Scout uh and Dr Gall Loft appears to be
no exception to that but does that
differ does that discredit his
allegations in your mind or I mean there
are going to be unsavory characters here
if we're talking about these types of
dealings I mean we're talking about the
bidens this is the bidens who face an
allegation that they took 10 million
dollars in foreign bribes and threatened
to pull a billion dollars in U.S aid
from Ukraine if the president didn't
fire the prosecutor and Ukraine
investigating barisma and the bidens
this is the Biden justice department
that just cut a sweetheart deal with
Hunter Biden on failing to file taxes
and giving a essentially a deferred
sentence on a felony gun charge to cover
up two years of millions and millions of
dollars of alleged foreign corruption
and bribes of the bidens I would say
about this whistleblower he named
specific names dates places amounts the
house oversight and or the house
Judiciary Committee and or the house
Ways and Means Committee need to start
issuing subpoenas for depositions of
these people at the justice department
these six specific officials at the
justice department that he named and
have them come in provide their
documents get the embassy official
officials in Brussels and run this down
yeah no doubt uh you know Miranda the
left will is surely we know what their
playbook looks like they're going to try
to downplay all of these allegations due
to his shady past but I don't remember
the left ever having a problem with
hyping I don't know like Michael Cohen
as the star witnessed against Trump I
mean they're they're Shameless in this
way so will he get a chance to actually
present this evidence either before the
committee uh or in a way that the public
will I mean there's so much smoke here
Miranda but the question is does it does
anyone ever hear the whistleblown
look he's on the run and you heard him
say he thinks he'll be on the Run for
the rest of his life
um he he tells me that he's really in
fear of his life as well so uh who knows
if he can testify by I don't know remote
video or by sending in a video I I don't
know how coma will figure that out but
what we do know is that the Democrats
are absolute Past Masters at trashing
every whistleblower that comes forward
and you're seeing in real time as
they're doing it to the IRS
whistleblower Gary shapley a man with an
impeccable record of honesty and
integrity who has recovered billions of
dollars for this country and you just
watch how they tear him down
yeah they will it's exactly right
Miranda and Mike thank you very much for
your time tonight we appreciate it hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else